يعني هل البعض ربما يشرب زهورات او اشياء
اعشاب يحاول انه ياهل نفسه للنوم ولكن لا
فائده او حتى البعض يذهب الى انه ياكل
دسمه ثقيله نعم للاسف هي هلا يمكن ما في
وقت نحكي عن الاليه المرض هذا المشكله
بيكون في انسداد نحن عم نحكي عن انقطاع
النفس النومي الانسدادي اللي هو بشكل اكثر
من 80% من انقطاع النفس عم نحكي في انسداد
بمجرى الهوائي العلوي هذا اللي بيؤدي
للشخير وبنفس الوقت بيؤدي لنقص الاكسجين
اثناء النوم
ما بيوصل بشكل كافي لانسجه الجزم مبيناتها
الدماغ اللي هو العضو الذبيين الاهم
بالجسم وهذا له اثر بكون اله اثر على
المدى الطويل
من من ضعف في النشاط من خمول من نقص
بفعاليات الجسم كلها
بما فيها
اسالك بشكل يعني سريع عن العلاج علاجه
يكمن في علاج اصل المشكله شو اللي بسبب
انقطاع النفس للاسف هو عاده البدانه طبعا
وعامل خطوره ممكن نعالج البدانه ممكن نعكس
البدانه ولكن العلاج عاده بيكون باستخدام
جهاز الضغط الايجابي اللي بنحطه على الفك
فهو مرض مزمن بده علاج مزمن وطويل الامد
احنا انت هل البعض يلجا الى جهاز الاكسجين
اثناء النوم هل هذا مفيد ولا هذا العلاج
الاساسي بصراحه هذا الاساس شكرا
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات